那么圣母心好不好？
如果她真的男真的吃不上饭了，
真的欠债了，
有别的女人愿意跟他吗？
你要比她还会哭穷才行，
你要比他还会装可怜才行，
是一个家庭主妇吧，
相当于孩子她爸，
她是出国呢，
帝国有3年多，
现在我带孩子，
他在外面挣钱，
他刚走的那两年吧，
感觉还可以，
赚钱什么的会多给我一些，
现在从去年冬天开始吧，
给我的钱很固定，
像给那个保姆发工资一样，
就说有时候可能会意，
有事儿的话不跟我要点儿，
他也会给，
但是很有钱，
而且从我跟他通话的时候，
他有一次不小心跟我还没有挂断电话的时候，
跟别人聊天，
我感觉他在那边应该是找人了，
而且在跟我就是通话什么的，
这个时间也是越来越少，
我再想离婚的话，
我觉得一是我也没有什么能力吧，
可能比较难，
再就是想看看有没有什么跟他好的沟通方式，
因为我也经常看你们的直播嘛，
怎么能我多有一点钱，
让他多给我点钱，
可能我有时候说话也说不太好吧，
脾气也比较急，
因为我老想着他在那边都有人了，
说话有时候也比较极端。
我后期个人规划这一块，
像你们是几个孩子，
两个孩子他一个月给你多少钱，
一般左右吧，
两个孩子多大了，
大的是初中，
那好说呀，
孩子需要啊，
需要更多的钱呀，
需要买什么课程啊。
啊，
需要参加什么培训啊，
需要一个什么辅导啊什么的，
需要给孩子买什么保险呀，
给孩子准备什么教育基金啊，
都是用钱的由头啊。
理姐他是这样，
他是一个思想很顽固的人，
大男子主义那种，
比如说给孩子招一个好一点的学校啊，
补课这些他都是不赞同的，
那你必须要转换你的思路了，
姐妹就是这个男人，
他不再是你的丈夫，
不再是你的老公了，
他跟孩子也没有什么感情的，
他跟孩子比如说前一阵孩子考试考好的话，
给他说了考好了，
其实我有没有丈夫都无所谓，
你看你这话说的有些话只能我没有跟他俩，
我没有跟他说，
我有时候会跟我朋友这样说，
我说他是应该在孩子身上多放一点精力的嘛，
就跟他说，
他也会给孩子一点奖励什么的，
我想表达的意思是你怎么才能够转变心态，
把这日子过好，
对，
是因为他常年不在身边，
孩子跟他的感情也深不到哪里去，
因为人就是这种动物，
就是得处才能有感情，
不处的话，
哪来的感情，
就是得一起去经历才有感情，
一起去经历一些高兴的事儿，
经历一些难过的事儿，
经历一些成长的瞬间，
他才有感情啊。
像你老公常年在国外，
跟孩子的话，
也不会有太深厚的感情，
那某种程度上的话，
你只是借助这个男人的力量去养大自己的两个孩子，
如果现在这个事情态，
因为有的孩子，
如果我自己带着的。
比如说扯上之后，
我自己带的话，
我确实没有这个能力，
而且在把他当成一个合作伙伴，
我们去把这个孩子养好就可以了。
对，
如果说他很固执，
那个不愿意给，
那就你看看，
你研究一下他愿意在哪些方面花钱，
这样对呀，
你研究一下他到底是，
比如说他喜欢买黄金，
那就撺掇他多打点钱回来买点黄金放着，
你研究一下他是喜欢买什么，
比如说他是喜欢买铺面，
好，
你就说哎，
我但是又发现一个打折的，
本来他是30万的铺面，
他今年15万就卖了，
你就撺掇他就把钱打回来置办这些家产，
你得研究他信什么，
但是我跟您说一下，
我觉得他现在可能已经没有心思往这边搞什么发展什么投资这一块他肯定不会做，
所以他现在心态应该就是有孩子，
他不能把孩子不管，
给钱，
只还尽那个义务去养孩子就完事了，
因为我那个小的刚上幼儿园了，
我也没有能力去做其他事儿，
我现做一个兼职，
一个月也就2000块钱收入，
我觉得我赚一点钱，
手里多有一点钱的话，
比如说哪天确实过不下去了，
他那边给我突然很有可能嘛，
哪天突然不给我钱了，
最起码孩子不会饿着，
他那头大给也能挣多少钱，
他最近老是说那边不好看，
之前考的时候一个月可以给到我5万左右吧，
那你手上有多少存款，
我现在没有太多吧，
十几个，
他现在哦，
能有这点责任心，
能有这点对。
孩子的心的话，
你得牢牢抓紧了，
不吵不闹，
就只说孩子的好，
只说孩子想爸爸了，
孩子今天又写了一个什么作文，
想爸爸了，
又有孩子今天又给我念叨，
爸爸要带我去哪哪哪可高兴了，
他现在只剩这一点良知，
你就得牢牢的抓我了，
这一点良知提现变现，
对，
因为他给我这些钱，
他父亲在，
他母亲在，
他母亲这点有什么事儿我都会管的，
反正他妈对我也挺好的，
虽然说经济上没有太大的帮助吧，
但是她会有力，
她会出一点力帮我带孩子什么的，
跟公公婆婆搞好关系，
坦率的说，
如果这个儿子将来在国外发展不回来了，
不想回来了，
那公公婆婆也得指着这俩孙子，
是不是因为你就当然不在了，
现在只有婆婆婆，
那婆婆也得指着这俩孙子，
那就给婆婆搞好关系的，
如果婆婆的财产将来能给孙子也是好的，
对婆婆的房子能给你们住也是很就是这样的，
他们家具农村嘛，
什么也没有，
想买房子车子什么也没有，
婆婆啥也没有是吧，
就很普通的对我对她好的话，
我也是不求他什么，
我是觉得她一个老人嘛，
没有姑娘也没有老公，
对我就觉得他挺可怜的，
她做不了的，
什么事儿需要我的时候我都会管他，
那你也得跟你老公说的呀，
你给我打点钱，
我想着给妈妈置办点啥，
我想着给妈妈。
弄点装修，
你给我打点钱，
我想给妈妈再装个空调啥的，
这一些我觉得反正很有戏，
因为他给我很多钱的时候，
比如说金额大一点的时候，
也没有几个月给完我那个钱之后，
他爸爸是生病嘛，
那时候我也管着他嘛，
相当于他们家的吃喝乱七八糟，
只要我去超市的话，
我一买都是两家人的那种，
他爸去世的时候，
他不是也没有能回来嘛，
相当于他爸出殡都是由我来弄的，
所以我手里钱花了一下嘛，
而且我这个钱经常也是会给他妈花，
包括孩子什么的，
那你自己，
你得张嘴呀，
我给你爸爸去病的时候花了多少钱，
我现在手上没钱了，
你得张嘴呀，
合理合法的由头，
这都不叫借口啊，
谁也不能拿人当借口，
这叫由头啊，
你确实花了钱了，
你确实得管他要啊，
得填平你这个账啊，
是不是啊，
但是我觉得时间过了，
他一直说我觉得我手里面有钱，
尽量花我手里面的钱，
因为他说他那时候确实啊，
他买车了，
什么买的车亏了，
而且说了很多，
因为不在一块儿，
我也不知道他那边什么情况，
他要是真吃不上饭了，
他哪有心思搞别的女人吗？
姐妹们啊，
你们真的是，
哎呦，
不要那么圣母心好不好？
如果他真的难，
真的吃不上饭了，
真的欠债了，
有别的女人愿意跟他吗？
你要比他还会哭穷才行，
你要比他还会装可怜才行，
你现在唯一剩下的就只有他对孩子和他妈妈的那点良心了，
如果你不趁着这个他还以。
有点良心的时候提现的话，
那以后他要是对孩子也没感情，
他妈在了之后，
你再从他身上搞不到一分钱，
对，
而且我觉得德国那边，
比如说他跟其他人的感情稳定之后，
他会在我这边撤离的更多，
对呀，
所以现在你就是第一不吵不闹的，
第二也不说什么难听的话，
第三某种程度上说的直在一点的话，
趁着他现在还有点良心的时候，
多给孩子预备一点，
好，
那就这样啊，
记得点赞关注哦。